c'est bien que l'union européenne
saisisse de ce dossier
ça a été évoqué en conseil européen
vendredi avec les chefs d'état et de
gouvernement l'idée d'avoir un pass
sanitaire qui permet d'avoir alors
justement en tension là il s'agit d'un
certificat vaccinale a priori au médical
qui permettrait de voyager
il ya aussi un autre dossier qui est sur
la table qu'il faut aussi travailler à
la fois juridiquement politiquement et
techniquement qui est la question d'un
pass and i ter qui permettrait d'aller
parler enfle au restaurant donc il ya
deux dossiers deux sujets en tout cas
c'est bien qu'au niveau européen la
question de la façon dont on se déplace
entre pays européens ou à l'extérieur de
l'union fonction tient ces deux projets
ont fait les deux à la fois le passé ni
terre et le pass vert numérique sur de
soutien en sont un soutien bien sûr
l'idée de travailler sur ces deux de ce
fait de dossier et ces deux sujets et
bien bien sûr trop tôt de les mettre en
oeuvre
puisqu'on en est que dans la première
phase de vaccination mais pour autant
c'est bien de les travailler que l'on
attendait parce que c'est ça évidemment
des impacts très importants à différents
titres sur les libertés publiques sur
les libertés individuelles sur l'équité
la justice la santé la confidentialité
de données médicales
il ya beaucoup de sujets qui doivent est
évoquée tant sur le bas dir pas
sanitaires pour aller au restaurant pour
aller au théâtre plutôt que ou à telle
autre activité ce qui est ou qui sont
aujourd'hui pas possible du fait de la
crise qu vide et deuxièmement certificat
médical qui permettrait de voyager d'un
pays de l'otan à l'extérieur de l'union
europe justement c'est une des
conditions aussi pour relancer les
échanges avec les pays voisins
on voit bien que la perturbation
engendrée par la crise qu vide a eu d
impact sur les échanges commerciaux en
2020 il ya eu un retrait des échanges
commerciaux au niveau mondial et donc
c'est vrai à la fois parce qu'il ya des
difficultés de se déplacer à titre
individuel mais aussi des difficultés
pour les produits et une marchande on se
savait porteur serait une porte de
sortie
en tout cas c'est un outil qui permet
peut-être de faciliter des échanges le
revenu mais bien sûr n'est pas encore du
tout à ce niveau de mises en oeuvre au
moment de la mise en oeuvre d'un tel
service est qu un moyen pas sanitaire
passeport vert c'est pas un moyen
d'imposer la vaccination obligatoire
non c'est différent en tout cas encore
une fois on voit que nous sommes dans
une phase de vaccination en europe qui
va prendre du temps et donc on en n'est
pas du tout à un niveau de d'imaginer la
vaccination obligatoire si tenté que ce
soit une bonne idée
en revanche l'idée d'avoir un outil qui
permette pour faciliter et fluidifier la
circulation d'avoir une forme de
certificat médical dont les modalités
sont à des images in et c'est évidemment
une idée à regarder de près c'est ce qui
était décidée lors du conseil européen
de vendredi et que la commission va
mettre en oeuvre mais il reste beaucoup
beaucoup de travail
prendre du temps vous dites fluidifier
la circulation mais c'est un retour aux
frontières c'est un échec aussi de
l'espace schengen non mais là on est
face à une crise inédite sanitaire qui
nécessite de prendre des décision
inédite
c'est ce que nous prenons c'est ce que
prennent un certain nombre de pays
européens c'est ce que prend l'union on
voit bien que dans l'avenir il faudra
qu'on pense mieux au niveau européen
aussi la gestion de ce type de crise
avait encore 7 l'as fin de semaine
dernière des discussions qui a eu entre
l'allemagne et la france sur le passage
de la frontière au niveau de leur
département de la moselle
on voit bien que dans l'avenir il faudra
structurer renforcer cision duration
santé les patients de santé vous pensez
qu'on reviendra en arrière
écoutez je sais pas je ne peux pas le
dire aujourd'hui en tout cas ce qui est
certain c'est que vu la crise que nous
traversons il ne faut pas exclure des
outils qui permettent de faciliter les
échanges entier
[Musique]